[Music]
we begin in Pakistan where at least 30
people have been killed in an explosion
in Mung in the southwestern baluchistan
Province several others were injured the
attack took place during a procession to
celebrate Idol ma nawi which is observed
as the birthday of the Prophet Muhammad
let's bring in our correspondent Kamal
Haider he joins us now from Islamabad
Kamal what more have you been able to
learn about
this well what we know so far is that uh
this procession or rally was taking
place in a town called must which is
about 50 kilomet West of qua it strad
the main uh Regional cooperation uh
development that is the rcd highway that
also links up to Iran now also linking
to the southern Port City of Karachi so
it's a junction uh 50 kilm away from qua
now today in Pakistan it is a national
holiday uh because of an occasion that
is called Eid Milad uni uh many people
think that the holy prophet's birthday
was today uh of course across Pakistan
because it's a holiday these processions
are coming out uh people are coming out
in large numbers and so there was an
explosion at one of those rallies a
suicide bomber is said to have
penetrated into the crowd he then
detonated his SU side explosive device
uh near a police official's vehicle a
senior police official he was killed
many other people killed the dead toll
has been mounting uh because of the
power of the explosives that were used
and of course a number of people killed
now those who were wounded seriously
because this is a remote region had to
be rushed to the city of qua the
provincial capital which is about 50
kilm away so the likelihood that the
dead troll May
go even
further right and right now it stands at
30 look there are regular attacks in
Pakistan Kamal especially in that part
of the country and it can come from
different groups put all of this in
context for us
please yes indeed in fact the groups
that are responsible for carrying out
attacks in the province include uh
baluch fighters from various outfits
also so the T Taliban Pakistan that have
taken responsibility for attacks in the
region however the T Taliban Pakistan
interestingly denied that they had
anything to do with this and that of
course would raise the alarm because uh
the Islamic State elements are quite
strong in this area as well and they may
be uh behind this particular attack but
no one has yet claimed the
responsibility baluchistan has seen many
attacks it has a ous border with
Afghanistan Pakistan has been saying
that many of the fighters have run away
from Afghanistan have established
themselves in certain small towns in
baluchistan as well as the kabuna
province now earlier this month there
was another deadly attack in which a
religious leader was badly wounded many
of his companions were also wounded in
an attack in the same area of
M all right so no claim of
responsibility yet uh Kamal Haider
reporting from Islamabad on this thank
you very much